how's going bros my name is Peter
playing Katherine part six
amazing how do you feel today
that is fantastic I use really Caroline
okay we're we're at the chapel or I
recall this who the [ __ ] are you let's
talk to she miss Hajin a misogynist
sheep that should be a new thing let's
say cuz I haven't done that in a while
and that seems like a fantastic way to
start a video just grab your attention
right away we're gonna talk to some more
sheeps
because I really want to make sure I get
everything out of this game this is the
guy that we met at the bar thing because
he has the glasses
I don't need their help to climb some
blocks but though by the way there's
this technique he just said that there's
well good look by yourself then really
what happens if you're teaching ice
evasion okay yeah no I figured that out
thank you I mean there's no way I would
have gotten here without not thinking
that all right let's knock do these do
that that's a police when you devise a
new technique teachers will let you know
that we'd come up with - let's work
together get out alive
I like the holloway the tutorials are
done in this game okay you know what I
take back what I said I don't want to
dread too much in this place right now
let's make our dinner our decision you
kill me in an instant if you wanted to
do you enjoy watching a scramble I think
that's a yes asking the questions this
is the sixth question situation will you
fight to win anything
which will obviously yes what about you
bros leave a comment thank you so much
it won't be like the previous levels why
not a stick this discussion is over
what's our true hallo mode Vincent's
true healthy
that things would change I guess he
seems so stuck in that all right let's
see what people answer question and
answer what no [ __ ] way
what about girls they're too interesting
they're still living one question where
we don't answer to the same thing we're
getting to the top a pop bap bap to the
tap run a random I'm sorry that was high
school musical I have a weird obsession
with it quadrangle second floor they
don't need to tell us that now they
should have told that before lies level
plus it was kept on my [ __ ] home
Fitz's level Jesus Christ
okay no problem
if you can't slide then oh god what do I
do here [ __ ] me I'm sucking ass
I can't pull this out I didn't think I
could pull those out well this is pretty
simple then no no no all right bro
well look at this [ __ ] and [ __ ] MLG
pro in this [ __ ] [ __ ] brauch look at
me I'm a mean just look at it we can do
this one as well and then we'll get the
pillow so there's a bar there we have to
go get it yeah I think that was a
sentence somewhere in there so the bar
recharges every time you go up a level
look it goes up again that's how the
combos work good thing I know that now
I'm a genius
why did I do that no one will ever know
push these away then we push that out
right and that's how it's done bris and
I lost my combo and I fell down because
I'm stupid god dammit that was so
unnecessary
that's how love and sprouts you fall off
an ice block and then it's is over and
then then you have to do a whole the
[ __ ] [ __ ] again there we go okay
we're back
I think nice look at that sweet edge
bros look at it let me can push this
over here and even one more time no God
why did I do that
god dammit alright it's okay though it's
okay we can save ourselves for day for
now a checkpoint would be [ __ ]
amazing right now alright alright
alright Matthew are you there Lord
Matthew anywhere please please if you
can hear this we should be fine I'm a
little worried that I'm gonna [ __ ] up
cuz I always [ __ ] up that's just my life
okay what does that do this oh my god I
almost [ __ ] died holy [ __ ] did I just
[ __ ] up keep a shoe out right yeah
that's how it's done that's how I get
all the ladies what do we do here
that worked can I go down I can go down
here right yeah I don't know how that
works
I'm sure it's physic related okay I'm
gonna get that Blancas I never used the
items but life is not about items bro
just remember that it's about sliding
off a block of the sheep and I'm okay
doing amazing
so proud of you look at that combo
aren't you looking what the [ __ ] am I
supposed to do now I can create a block
maybe I didn't mean to walk off
goddamnit I create a block look at that
beautiful beaut oh so nice look at that
[ __ ] goddamn it I [ __ ] up I didn't know
how the [ __ ] Oh God
[ __ ] genius move right there bro see
that [ __ ] you don't see that on the news
every day I don't know why you'd see it
on the news
please go down go down
I need you to go down
there we go how the [ __ ] do I get up
there what the [ __ ] oh yes oh ha ha that
was so I'm so happy I was really hard I
was really struggling on that one
genius parents yes I know thank you very
much thank you so much I really really
do appreciate it
this is gonna be a bronze for sure but
it's okay it's not okay hey
and we're not done alright more sheep to
talk to you okay
tell me sucker this [ __ ]
what about this guy talk about
techniques yeah it's
what he's gonna kill me with his axe
what do you mean [ __ ]
I don't know but you have great hair
damnit they've attained sorry I was just
funnin trying to [ __ ] how so sorry
let's go in more question time bros no
it wasn't if you saw how many times I
replayed you wouldn't say that one of me
is enough I I hate the idea that your
kid has to be like you and that was a
bad answer apparently I think this one
is gonna be really split what do you
guys think thank you because I'm so
close to the top Katherine isn't it
tonight escaping is the only way to
survive I have to do it okay then let's
go the night will be over soon too
well true hell is coming breasts clench
your buttcheeks it's gonna be a nice one
let's see what other people answer I
think is gonna display not too much
split than I thought
girls want more than men that their
children are like them I thought it
would be the opposite that man wants
their son or daughter to be like that oh
well we're nearing the end of day 4
final floor of quadrangle stage 5 damn
this game goes fired back so fast like a
little kid alright it should be alright
it should be alright I'm a little
worried for us it is Catherine what does
oh my god no I hate the bosses they're
so hard Catherine I love you I love you
my gun to my god please don't kill me
with your wedding you do that no [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] don't kill me Catherine oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] hit me calm down Jesus Christ
okay I don't know what she's doing right
now but I know my god
look how it look up there oh my god I
didn't see ya Oh God you better go there
what the hell is with me what that was
with you
please don't pissing you off that's
great come on don't hit me I can't
[ __ ] see this is Craig where's the
checkpoint please be a checkpoint soon I
would really be a big fan oh my [ __ ]
god she's [ __ ] terrifying
Oh God Oh Oh what what that what what
happened man I got a [ __ ] please don't
kill me yeah well I'm [ __ ] pissed off
too how about that have you thought
about my [ __ ] feelings and [ __ ] oh my
god
I'm [ __ ] sweating balls there's balls
coming out of myself the checkpoint is
over there are you kidding me Oh God
well [ __ ] me in my checkpoints then I
guess fantastic you know what I'm going
for it sometimes in life okay oh we're
almost there almost there
yes yes yes yes oh I love it I love it
so much baby girl
won't you please go on a date with me
I'm
yes come on broach we can do this can I
get a hey yo oh god they're falling
they're falling in [ __ ] [ __ ] like
this game wasn't harden block what are
you doing you're drunk go home what do I
do here please fall down
what am I
the [ __ ] just happened oh my god oh my
god oh my god did I I didn't walk yeah
feels so good
Jesus Christ
riding the giris by ramming them over
the female area and you killed your
girlfriend bro you kill your Efrain you
Pig
hallelujah indeed we did it
hundred percent five hundred percent
maybe even could I even dare say six
hundred percent but there's no such
thing unfortunately we got a bronze
prize Bruce I feel very happy about that
very very happy can't you see the smile
on my face thank you a lot of people say
I have a beautiful smile let's see what
time is it did we wake up now I think I
think we woke up yeah that's the boss
fifth day Vincent's room 5:30 but this
was just the beginning the [ __ ] is this
how the [ __ ] did he get our number
Majid her boyfriend yeah I started I was
planning to do in the first place in the
first place yeah I never thought it
would end up this way yeah everyone
threatens to kill me this is fantastic
that is the question well at least now I
can resolve this situation with her he
said his name was Steve
in any case Katherine's gotta agree to
break up with you once I tell her about
this I'll see her one more time to have
a talk
I had a feeling she was home
[ __ ]
wasn't it 5:00 in the morning Jesus
that's team that could have been Steve
so paranoid jeez what the [ __ ]
back in tomorrow did you just tell me
that this guy's Steve's that he's your
boyfriend huh he said he was my
boyfriend yeah he said he was
Katherine's boyfriend hmm are we talking
about the other cat the entirely wrong
I mean she's been so absent too with her
work maybe she's cheating both of us can
be happy with multiple partners maybe
then the kid isn't ours now my plan to
break up with Katherine with this Steve
information is ruined she finds out
about Katherine now I am totally [ __ ]
I need to play this off there's gotta be
countless men that have fallen for you
right maybe one of them is still trying
to get you to fall for him anyway maybe
this guy's not even named Steve probably
some creeper trying to act slick stop
you're scaring me oh sorry you know what
let's just drop it
hey you're the one that brought it up
so Catherine is cheating on him alright
are you listening oh sorry I kind of
kind of zoned out there you know being
with you as a real piece Wow
I'm going now yeah no wait you decided
seriously tonight is not a good time for
me yeah seriously there's no point in
going oh why are we talking to the other
Catherine oh my god get the Rinku caster
Rincon Catherine can gather in Kern our
friends are here fantastic
oh is meeting new people for work plus
she doesn't always choose the best all
this time don't you get it
it isn't about length she's you men are
such pigs next time she's here
tell me man don't wanna see her yeah
this wasn't supposed to be a meet-up
this sauce sounds like a huge pig come
on stop being so down you don't even
know if she's really cheating right no
so what are you gonna do now what else
can I do I have to know seriously I'm
just in shock now in shock my ass even
if it's true you're not in sin deeper
you're just a selfish Pig she's right
you know
I know I know I'm doing the same thing I
knew she was lying to me I couldn't take
it I am
hey Benson I can't watch this anymore
everyone is in the same situation with
us it's like you know the dream where
you're falling and you'll die if you hit
the ground before you wake up lately a
lot of customers have been talking about
having strange dreams
I wonder one that's just stupid how's
anyone supposed to know what dream the
dying person had they're dead it's just
a dream and real right Vincent he's
already dead
seriously is he gonna be okay I'm not
dead yet
what's going on I'm so confused
alright so now we can talk I'm actually
gonna end it here
so yeah you bros thank you for all this
part I'm having so much fun playing this
game leave a like if you enjoyed
watching and keep keep it up I really
appreciate it keep them coming and I'll
see you the next one as always stay
awesome press